enter
[music]
I think I don't know how they wanted to
strip to the waist or below the waist but
I think that it would be a
disgusting sight in any case, well,
if you remember Pushkin, I can make a mistake
there in the words in detail, but in my opinion he said
to be a practical person  and
think about the beauty of the nails the
saint
[music] a
person should be all harmoniously
developed, both soul and body, but in order for
everything to be so harmonious,
you need to give up
alcohol abuse, other bad habits,
go in for physical culture and sports,
all in the knee of which you said I them
all  I know personally that we do
n’t have the best period of our relationship,
this is understandable, but nevertheless they are all people,
they are leaders, which means they have character and if
they want they
will certainly achieve the desired success, but
you need to work on yourself, otherwise what they
say about it is already good for that  praised
and
either were deprived of the right and turn it on
they are lollipops and we will have a balcony
maxik on the skeleton.
but I won’t say now if
it were, I just want to
recall the events of recent history in this regard, when
Margaret Thatcher decided to start
hostilities against Argentina
for the Lena Islands, so the woman
decided to start
hostilities where those Athens islands and where
Britain means and it is dictated by nothing more
than imperial ambitions to
confirm its imperial status,
so I think that in any case, from the
current Prime Minister of
Great Britain, this is not a very not very
correct reference to
what is happening today